welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler i am the
special temporary primary host of the
show today i am joined by greg knuckles
he is currently for the time being the
permanent guest co-host for now
if you enjoy the show and you'd like to
support it there are many ways you could
do that you could like rate or subscribe
wherever you get podcasts you could join
our newsletter we send out an email with
a bunch of research updates
you could do that by going to
strongerbyscience.com
newsletter
you could check out our coaching program
we offer
one-on-one virtual online coaching
for various endeavors related to
strength and fitness and sports
nutrition you can check that out at
strongerbyscience.com
coaching you could use our discount code
at bulksupplements.com
the code is sbs pod it gets you five
percent off your order you can check out
the mass research review which we
publish every single month or you can
check out our diet app which is called
macro factor and it does offer a free
trial
all right uh road to the stage how's it
going
road to the stage is going well so after
uh after a couple somewhat rocky weeks
i hit a new low this week both in terms
of scale weight and trended weight
uh 224.2
i feel pretty good about that uh and
just as an update on two things so i
mentioned i think maybe three or four
episodes ago
that i was kicking around the idea of
maybe trying to get under 225 and then
taking a break for a little bit
uh still feeling good so
i'm gonna push it to at least 220 and
then and then maybe reevaluate from
there
and then the other thing just to give a
brief update on is i think i mentioned
either last episode or two episodes ago
that i was trying a little experiment
with my diet where uh pretty much all
i'm eating is just meat and fruit and uh
so far it's going great
uh satiety is excellent most fruit very
high on the satiety index uh loving the
food
itself uh i love fruit um so you know
having that
be close to two-thirds of my diet is
excellent well close to two-thirds by
calories but
probably like eighty percent by just
like pure volume uh and it's also been
unexpectedly great for hydration so at
most meals i'm eating like a kilogram of
fruit fruit is mostly water so
that is in effect similar to drinking a
liter of water with most meals
i
am chronically under hydrated i don't
like drinking things i find it annoying
wish humans didn't have to drink i wish
we were more like cats so if you've ever
wondered why cat piss smells so bad it's
because they have hyper efficient
kidneys and are really really good at
concentrating uh everything down so that
their
urine is like hyper concentrated and
also uh i believe this is true i don't
think cats sweat uh so like they lose
water via exhalation and they minimize
water loss
via urination and don't really lose
water otherwise so they don't have to
drink that much
and i wish humans were the same way that
would be ideal
this this is a fun fact about cats that
i that i am quite confident is true uh
so you know how humans can't drink salt
water like if you're stranded in the
ocean that will on that dehydrate you
you can but it won't get you far correct
so cats can't actually hydrate
themselves on ocean water like that is
that is how efficiently they can uh they
can concentrate solutes in their urine
so
anyway wish i was a cat but i'm not uh
and given that set of facts eating fruit
has been good for keeping me hydrated
now we took a kind of like a company
stronger by science trip uh to the zoo
this past year
and i remember seeing a lot of very
muscular primates eating a lot of fruit
do you feel like you're getting any of
those benefits um getting
maybe super human strength
uh
no but that would be cool
um
because so
there were some themes like that and the
game changers documentary that i take at
face value i'm wondering if it panned
out yeah so i i've posted about this
before uh and and every time it comes up
in my facebook memories i reshare it
because i think it's cool um but yeah
like from time to time people will be
like oh yeah like gorillas they're super
jacked uh
they eat either no meat or very little
meat uh most of the foods they eat are
low protein so how are they so jacked
and it's like well first they're they're
a different species and that's damn it i
knew there was something i was missing
that's potentially relevant
uh you know
elephants elephants are herbivores
they're [ __ ] jacked but
they're uh turns out a different animal
yeah
so you know that's one thing but the
other thing is like yeah uh gorilla
physiology is more similar to human
physiology than say elephant physiology
is uh but the thing with with uh
gorillas is it doesn't matter
really the protein content of the food
they eat because they eat so much
goddamn food uh
again i didn't pull this up before we
started recording didn't know we'd be
talking about gorillas but if memory
serves they eat
either
around 20 kilograms of food per day or
around 40 kilograms of food per day it's
one of the two it's just an absurd
amount of food and it is enough food
that like they'll eat some bugs they'll
eat some fruit they'll eat some leaves
they'll eat some bark uh and with the
exception of bugs all of those are
relatively low protein but when you just
kind of like average it out and math it
out given the amount of food they're
eating they're probably still getting in
like
250 300 grams of protein per day just
because they're eating
so much food um
so yeah no i'm i'm not eating that much
unfortunately so i do
i do still have to have some
protein-rich foods in my diet uh but if
i could eat as much food as a gorilla
and not have to to worry about that that
would be pretty cool
yeah and just the the kind of standard
disclaimer you are not doing this to
mimic the purportedly health promoting
diet of
what what is it carnivore md or uh
saladino i can never remember if it's
paul saladino or joey saladin it's paul
okay yeah
okay but um but i i did see one of his
posts the other day where he was
uh kind of speaking out against the use
of soap and toothpaste have you adopted
any of those well i'm in the room i i
would be able to tell i think uh
well
well i
i i beat him to the punch on the no soap
thing uh
here's a
here's a beauty tip from the stronger by
science podcast oh boy uh
so i
i
not infrequently get compliments on my
skin i have very clear skin uh
people ask me what do you do my answer
nothing so i shampoo my hair that's it
everything else just rinse off with
water uh
and
i think that uh
i don't know i think that my my
physiology is perfectly adapted to this
the southern sweltering heat and my skin
produces the correct amount of oils to
stay hydrated and vibrant um
but yeah no i i
have never really
used soap
that's bad but i do brush my teeth okay
that's good uh all right feed the
strength what do you got feats of
strength so uh
uh ipf worlds were uh were recent they
took place recently and so there were a
lot of big performances and instead of
trying to go through all of them in one
segment i think i'm going to split it up
between two weeks
and so in this one i'm going to talk
about the women's side of things and
next week i'm going to talk about
big performances on the men's side of
things so starting with the light
weights
tiffany chapon uh
is just laying waste to the lightweight
classes she competed at uh at 43 for
quite a while she moved up to 47 a
couple years ago uh still holds the
total world record at 43 and uh she
set or broke her own world record at 47
can't remember which um but she she has
like 18 kilos of clearance over second
place now and uh she also broke the
squad and bench press world records in
the 47 class as well just a truly
dominant performance she uh she owns
those two lightest weight classes for
now uh moving on to 52 kilos
uh plune decker and noemi alabair had a
great squat battle at 52
they hit the two all-time biggest squats
uh in that weight class with deckers
winning out by half a kilo
she squatted 168 and a half to 168 even
for aliber
also in the 57 class donna berglund set
a bench press world record at 123 kilos
which is like 271 so huge bench in that
class
um
moving on to deadlift uh fareed farhana
who
i had never heard of before this is this
is her first uh recorded meet in the
open powerlifting database um
she just rolls up and pulls a 200 and a
half kilo deadlift at 52 kilos which is
uh
what 442
at
like 114 so that's that's a monstrous
pull and in the 57 kilo class uh joy
nomani
from great britain i believe
pulled 228 kilos at 57 and
in in freedom units that pull breaks the
500 pound barrier in that weight class
which
again just uh just a tremendous pull
from her uh and then
bobby butters who currently holds the 57
kilo
squat record at
185 uh won one gold for the squad in the
meet with a 183 squat shout out to her
uh
she is a macro factor affiliate very
cool you should follow her
and then finally probably the the battle
of the event not just on the women's
side of things but for the entire
competition was the battle at 76 kilos
uh between jessica bittner and agata
sitko
um
so
it was like it was like a heavyweight
title fight with just two
two monsters just trading
uh just trading haymakers in the middle
of the ring so starting off with the
squat uh jessica bittner set a squat
world record at 218.5
to to put her ahead coming out of the
gate moving on to bench sitko fires back
uh hits a world record of her own at 145
kilos to to pull ahead in the subtotal
so it all comes down to the deadlift uh
where uh jessica bittner needs to pull
261 and a half for a world record and
the heaviest deadlift ever pulled on the
women's side of things in ipf
competition ever
so it all comes down to
can she pull one of the best deadlifts
ever pulled in the ipf and she does she
pulls it off
and they actually tied in the total so
they they both uh they both set the
world record for the total in that
weight class but uh jessica won on body
weight she weighed in at
75.2 compared to citco 75.6
so it was
as close as a meat could possibly well i
guess they could have been 0.1 kilo away
in bodyweight instead of 0.4 but within
reason it's as close as a head-to-head
battle in powerlifting could possibly be
with uh
with world record set on every lift uh
all like all throughout the battle
and uh
ending with a tie in both people setting
world record totals so uh congrats to
them uh huge huge performance also
jessica bittner macro factor affiliate
check her out as well man there must be
something a macro factor a lot of
success i don't think
it has yeah maybe it helped them make
weight don't think it has anything to do
with with the weights they're lifting
but uh i'm comfortable taking all the
credit sure okay
uh
that would be cool though yeah um so
speaking of macro factor we've got uh a
brief tech support segment here
um that actually corresponds with
an article that we put out so we uh kind
of
revamped and launched uh the macro
factor website itself you know we had
been kind of
housing some macro factor content on
stronger by science uh but now macro
factor has its own website
macrofactorapp.com
and we've got a new article uh
if you go to
macrofactorapp.com
fastest food logger so that's kind of
the the tease for what this segment is
about do you want to give a little
insight about
what the article covers um basically the
big food logger revamp uh yeah sure i
was uh i was going to review my notes
while you did your your next segment but
yeah let's see if i can do this off the
dome so
our hurdle when it comes to
getting into food logging or sticking
with food logging once it's become a
habit
is just simply the amount of time it
takes to log food and the friction
associated with that so you know if
you're going to eat a meal and not log
it versus eat a meal and log it not
logging it saves time it's one less
thing you need to think about one less
thing you need to worry about
so trying to minimize the amount of time
effort and friction associated with food
logging
you know seems like a pretty important
thing to focus on
so
after macro factor came out um corey and
rebecca are our developers they did a
ton of market research to
try to figure out how to make our food
logger even more efficient like it was
one of the more efficient on the market
to begin with in terms of the total
number of caps or discrete actions that
it took to accomplish core food logging
workflows uh but there were some apps
that beat us on some flows so they did a
ton of research to figure out how to
save actions wherever possible um while
still providing all of the context and
information you would need and want
when uh when logging food and so that
that all rolled out uh within the past
month or so
uh and and in association with the new
food logger and
um you know in order to know
whether or not we had accomplished the
goal we wanted to
corey created a
scoring system for ranking the speed of
the speed and efficiency of food loggers
and one thing i'll note is this wasn't a
system that was designed after the fact
in order to make macro factor's food
logger look good
it was a system designed on the front
end to one figure out how our food
logger stacked up to others
and then two to
essentially essentially evaluate whether
the redesign and the revamp did what we
wanted it to do
so in his system there are four use
cases so one is logging foods via search
like searching for the food one is
logging foods via multi-ad one is
logging foods via barcode scanning and
one is just quick adding
calories or macros without logging a
food associated with them
and because those are the ways that most
people are going to be logging most
foods most of the time and so
essentially it's just a matter of
counting up how many taps or discrete
actions it takes to log food via those
flows and
the new macro factor food logger is
either the fastest or tied for the
fastest across all four of those flows
and is uh considerably faster than than
anything else out there now by by a
pretty hefty margin um so yeah if uh
if you currently log food or you've
previously logged food and you just
think like uh like this is
i i see benefits from it but just the
act of logging food itself is a chore um
give macro factor a shot it might
provide
a a
enough of a reduced amount of friction
that it goes from being something that
is too onerous of a chore to stick with
to
uh
you know only a bit of a chore and uh
not not as annoying as logging food and
other apps so
uh yeah check out macro factor and check
out the article itself which will be
linked in the show notes if you want to
read it and uh dig further into the
scoring methodology yeah and you know we
felt it was important to make the
article
public and kind of publish it in that
format just because you know
any food logger is going to come out and
say actually did you know that our food
logger is
very good and fast like everyone's going
to say that so the reason we published
the article is so that you can actually
take a look at the methodology that goes
into it
and kind of rigorously examine the tasks
that were completed and how efficiency
was basically
uh objectively quantified within this
system so uh yeah like greg said uh it's
definitely worth checking out especially
if you have previously checked out macro
factor and you're like you know what i
was hoping for something that was an
even more efficient logging process um
you know we still have a free trial
check it out again see if you like the
new logger and go from there yeah i mean
ultimately our goal with macro factor is
we want it to be
not just the best like quote unquote
diet coaching app uh but just the the
best food logger period um so
we think that uh we think we've
accomplished that i mean honestly
so
in terms of
things that someone might be looking for
when when using a food logger
the
the only major area where i perceive
that any of our competitors presently
still have a leg up over us
is in database size and and that's only
for a couple apps so you know
myfitnesspal is always going to have the
biggest database they have the most
users they've been around forever they
also have 170 entries for an oreo and
that some percentage of them are correct
yeah that is also true there there is
the highest odds that you will find what
you're looking for and also the highest
odds that it might take you a little
while to find what you're looking for
like it it's probably in there but there
might be some some chaff you have to
wade through uh and and lose it is
comparable um
so also this the same type of deal a
largely user-submitted database huge
database fair number of inaccurate
entries is both not quite as big but
also not quite as cluttered as
myfitnesspal um and then for for central
european users specifically
yazio i think has has the best database
for that market um
but then kind of the the next tier down
from that you you're going to find a lot
of other very large successful apps so
uh like my net diary for instance
chronometer
um
who else fat secret uh
and our our database is
comparable to those so you know
that is one key area where
i would say macro factor is kind of on
the second tier of competitors in in
terms of just total size of database for
everything else i mean i
like this is obviously not a completely
unbiased assessment but i i do think we
have the best food logging system out
there uh i think is in in terms of just
the diet coaching app space uh i think
that our app does that better than our
competitors um so yeah it's it's still
relatively new but i feel
i feel really really good about uh the
state of the app as it exists now like
we're yeah we're not just trying to swim
in the kiddie pool like we're we're
going after the big dogs in the space
and and trying to compete head-to-head
with them yeah and there are two things
to keep in mind with the database so the
first one as we've kind of alluded to is
i mean we can make the database bigger
tomorrow if we just said hey everybody
uh put in a bunch of entries but but
what's really nice about our current
database is that it is rock solid in
terms of accuracy so there's kind of
that
uh that trade-off there where if you
start to invite user submitted
entries without a pretty good
verification system
you can run it into a situation where
you say great bigger database but now i
have to spend twice as much time
figuring out which foods i want to
actually log
and our database we did if you tried it
when we first launched
we took
a pretty big step in improving that
database
to get more coverage in other countries
outside of the united states
so i think we've mentioned that on the
podcast previously but if you tried
macro factor like right around the time
it launched and you were in
uh you know you were outside of the
united states and saying i wish there
was a little more coverage it might be
worth checking out again just to see if
if what we did to uh bolster that
database uh specifically enhanced
coverage in your country yeah and just
one more thing to add so you know if
you're listening to this and you're like
hey i'm not going to pay for
a food logger that's totally fair
totally understandable
so to make sure that this uh that this
segment
still contains
information that's useful and valuable
even for people who don't want to use
macro factor
what i would encourage you to do if
you're currently a myfitnesspal user is
to try
something else uh like
as as someone who is now
a competitor in the food logger space
and has has done a fair bit of
competitor analysis
uh
myfitnesspal
isn't that great of software like i
think it's just the default because it's
been around for so long and has the
largest market share and i think that
there's
the natural inclination to assume that
if something has the most users it must
therefore necessarily be the best but in
terms of of just like the free food
loggers on the market
myfitnesspal is not that good so if
you're currently using myfitnesspal you
don't want to pay for something but you
you would just like to use a free food
logger
i would recommend potentially checking
out lose it like i mentioned before
database comparable to myfitnesspal
but far more efficient food logging
flows and it's just a slicker piece of
software
i would also recommend checking out
mynetdiary so it is one that does use a
verified food database so you won't have
to worry about sifting through as many
inaccurate entries uh it also has a lot
more efficient food logging flows than
than myfitnesspal does also a really
solid app if you if you don't want to
pay for something and uh chronometer as
well so it doesn't have hyper efficient
food logging flows
but in terms of the free apps out there
i think it probably has the best overall
database especially for people who are
interested in tracking micronutrients as
well
but yeah for
for most people i i would recommend one
of those three over myfitnesspal just
just for free food logging and i and i
don't make a dime off of those
recommendations
but you know if if you don't want to to
pay money and try out macro factor all
three of those apps in the free food
logging space are considerably better
than than myfitnesspal so if you get
annoyed with myfitnesspal and decide
like yeah you know i i want to look
around a little bit see what's out there
um those are those are three very solid
free apps
nice
all right uh next segment here i'm not
really sure what it would fall under in
terms of our
our standard segment names but this is
just uh just talking [ __ ] just updates
related to science uh and i'm going to
start out with the conclusions uh the
conclusions are twofold first of all if
you're someone who reads science paper
by paper
just be careful out there folks
i'm going to talk about a couple trends
i'm seeing that seem to be catching you
know catching some momentum here and i'm
not
not fond of the trends
uh the other conclusion is that uh this
is something if you're a mass subscriber
you've kind of heard me allude to this
probably twice now
in audio roundtables but
i think the hierarchy of evidence
is within our field becoming less and
less helpful as a heuristic
and the hierarchy of evidence you know
the thing i'm really referring to is
um
lending special status to the systematic
review and meta analysis
traditionally speaking
that would be at the top of the
hierarchy of evidence you would consider
it to be the highest level of evidence
the uh lowest risk of bias and things of
that nature uh but what i propose is
that you know remember back in the day
when we were kids they had the uh
the food pyramid
in the united states and there's all the
grains at the bottom and then fruits and
vegetables and meat and dairy yeah and
then uh oils at the top and oils and
sweets and stuff yeah uh and then all of
a sudden they're like actually psych
these are gonna be all vertical tears
and then we're gonna have somebody
walking up the side of the pyramid just
kind of scaling the entire thing saying
like hey you should also exercise
i think we need to kind of reshape the
hierarchy of evidence and just have meta
analyses
just kind of floating around it like an
electron cloud ooh there is something
like that well while you're talking i i
will pull it up it's it's a cool little
graphic that i think we could put in the
show notes yeah but anyway so that's
those are my my conclusions
uh i want to talk about
why i have arrived at those conclusions
i i saw a very uh insightful tweet
by um
patty
kiss
i i don't know i'm gonna i'm gonna
link his profile uh because i i did find
it to be very uh
an an interesting trend that he pointed
out so he he plotted a little graph here
um
looking at pubmed pubmed entries per
year going all the way back to like the
looks like the 80s
and one line is plotting randomized
controlled trials over time
uh
within exercise science
and the other line is plotting uh
systematic reviews uh over time
and what's happened i mean if you've
been loosely following the literature
you've probably noticed within the last
few years like man
there's really a trend going on here
with a lot more systematic reviews and
meta analyses but what's really
interesting is that there was kind of
like an inflection point
back around 2015-ish
where
systematic reviews in our field and this
is an informal analysis i'm sure
uh but
there's a divergence where systematic
review started outpacing randomized
controlled trials yeah and theoretically
the idea with a systematic review is
that
uh
you know there's a body of literature
that's growing and growing and growing
through
you know kind of primary pieces of of
research you know
randomized controlled trials when it's
feasible to do so or other types of
research depending on the question
and then as that body of literature
accumulates you say you know what i
think this literature is ripe it's ready
for
a systematic review and
if in doing that systematic review i
realized that quantitative summary would
be appropriate i might even do a
meta-analysis
along with that systematic review of the
literature
and that's just simply not the way
systematic reviews and meta-analyses
seem to be functioning in our field over
the last few years yeah there certainly
are some that do that but man you know
you look back over the last few years
and you see so many meta analyses that
are like
yeah we had uh
we had three studies so i i'll give you
a little diamond at the bottom of the
plot yeah um and even one thing i saw
recently that kind of broke my heart as
a systematic review purist
um i'm one of those sociopaths that
reads the reviewer reports
for the journals that publish them
yeah so like some journals will publish
not just the finished paper but also
the
comments from peer reviewers throughout
the rounds of review
uh sometimes i dig into those and i came
across one the other day
and it was it was like
it was really alarming to me because
they were like yeah this is a fine
narrative review but like
it would sure be cooler and more
exciting if it just was instead a
systematic review yeah and so the the
the underlying logic there was not
this literature demands a systematic
review and it would have
much more value and utility it was just
like hey systematic reviews are very
fashionable right now you should go
ahead and retrofit a systematic search
and go from there
so to me i think one of the things
that's really um potentially a troubling
set of trends in the field
is that people seem to be more
interested in the brand or like the
marketability of a systematic review or
a meta-analysis rather than the actual
utility of what a
really well-done systematic review or
meta-analysis provides
and so
that's kind of what i'm getting at when
i say with this hierarchy of evidence
yes a really well done systematic review
or meta analysis
when done on a body of literature or a
research question that is suitable for
that uh is excellent you know it is
still a tremendous form of evidence and
the highest level of evidence but man
you know
you it's becoming apparent sometimes uh
when you open up a review and you say
there's no way this started as a
systematic review or
maybe it did but it absolutely shouldn't
have and like this does not possess the
the qualities and characteristics that
make a systematic review so effective
and special as a form of evidence well i
i mean you you know why that is right
like
so there's
i i think in large part it's people just
responding rationally to incentives so
if you're if you're trying to
uh both both grow your cv and like
trying to improve your h index or
something like that um
you know a lot of work does go into a
systematic reviewer meta-analysis like a
lot of work goes into just about any
type of discrete scientific output but
the amount of work and effort that goes
into it is
almost always considerably less than the
amount of work and effort that would go
into
like conducting an original study
and in addition to that if you're so
like one you can you can crank out
reviews faster and and kind of pad out
that cv and then the other thing is to
to demonstrate um you know both both
your research output but also that
people like read and cite your research
output um metrics like agent indices and
just general citation counts uh reviews
review papers get cited a lot more on
average than original research does so
if you're responding to those incentives
like you're trying to to boost your h
index and just trying to get more pubs
on your cv uh
you will one imp generally improve your
h index more with a decent systematic
review or meta-analysis than you would
with most original research that's not
always true you know if you publish a
groundbreaking study in some
brand new area of research like that's
going to get cited a lot but for the
most part if there's like 15 studies on
a topic already if you do a
meta-analysis on those 15 studies it's
going to get cited more than just the
16th study on that topic uh and yeah
it's it's generally quicker and easier
to do so like i i understand why people
are doing it
yeah and it's good for the journals
because
they're they're uh they're getting cited
more so it it improves the journal's
impact factor yeah yeah i get it and by
the way you mentioned uh the time
investment for a systematic review or
meta-analysis someone who works in a
different academic field
uh might have
fainted when here oh yeah yeah it is
worth noting in exercise physiology yeah
a lot of the meadows that we're talking
about here we're talking about a
meta-analysis on you know four six eight
ten studies
um and sometimes that's warranted
depending on on the the type of data
that are available
but um
but any you know
my my girlfriend did a phd in psychology
and like when they do a meta-analysis
it's
you're talking about at least four
digits in the number of studies included
in most cases you're talking about
thousands not uh
not six i mean this is something we've
talked about before off mike but if if
anything in our field it seems like
people might be afraid of doing
meta-analyses when there will be a lot
of studies and it will therefore take a
lot of time and effort like yeah uh one
of one of the areas you've brought up
before is like creatine research yeah
where the last time there was a meta on
uh the impact of creatine
supplementation on hypertrophy and
strength outcomes didn't you say it's
like 2011 or something no oh god no it's
like 2003. okay so it's [ __ ] old uh
now now
there are updates since then that are in
special populations yeah yeah so people
will be like oh we're gonna look in the
elderly right and find like
17 studies you know but yeah like just a
broad like hey we know there's been like
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of creatine studies has anyone
kind of stitched those together for a
meta to my i haven't seen it to my
knowledge that hasn't happened no i i
believe you're correct and that would be
really valuable but yeah i mean like
like you said uh
a meta can
absolutely take a ton of time and effort
if there are enough studies there there
are very few
bodies of research in our field that do
have that many studies and the ones that
do exist tend to not have recent metas
on them so i i do think uh you know
getting a pub for slightly less effort
is at least to some extent a motivation
there yeah yeah and just kind of one
thing that jumped out because i
i was looking at just like the
proliferation of just the number of
papers that that are coming out because
like part of me was wondering if we
would start to see a bit of a dip um
post covid in our field with
lab shutting i mean everyone i know who
worked in a lab it was shut down for a
considerable amount of time and of
course i understand people have studies
sitting in the file drawer people have
reviews that they were planning to do
they've got studies that have been
conducted six years ago they're going to
publish but man i was looking at mdpi's
numbers for publications per year in
2018 mdpi which has it's
multi-disciplinary that's what the m
stands for
and the d yeah
but uh
they published in 2018 67 000 papers
that climbed steadily and in 2021 they
published
240 000 papers
and you know they have several journals
within our field and one of the things
i've noticed is that with this
uh rapid increase in re narrative review
systematic reviews meta analyses
it seems that there's a lot of people
who are publishing
the these papers that's like
yeah i either couldn't do a study the
last couple years or
maybe didn't want to
but i'm just going to kind of carve out
an angle here on a particular topic and
put a review out there and they're
getting picked up and published very
rapidly and you know
they're all over the place i mean the
number of papers coming out in this
field is so high these days
and in some cases i do think that it
leads to potentially more confusion
rather than clarity because we're
getting so many more perspective papers
out
and not nearly enough just pieces of
like hey here's original scholarship
with new data uh a well-designed
experiment that answers a specific
question yeah and of course there's
there's people doing that no question
but but yeah just if you're someone
who's out there digging through the
literature piece by piece um
and you know you really lean heavily on
the hierarchy of evidence as a heuristic
um i just think it's important to
recognize that that heuristic is
in my opinion getting chipped away at a
little bit
as systematic reviews are
no longer quite resembling what they
were intended to be within our field
yeah so the the paper i had in mind that
proposed a slight update to the the
pyramid of evidence
is by murad and colleagues i i linked it
in the show notes it's it's right there
like at the top of this section um but
it's called a new evidence pyramid by
murad and colleagues published in bmj uh
evidence-based medicine
and uh
it basically proposes that instead of
just having that pyramid with straight
lines across uh denoting the separation
between different types of research uh
one instead of straight lines they
should be kind of wavy so you know i
know what it looks like what it looks
like
when i was in junior high they gave us
the glasses to make it seem like you're
drunk oh yeah like hey try to walk a
straight line the drunk goggles yeah
that's what it looks like it does kind
of uh yeah they could have gotten a
better designer um but yeah so
uh you know from the bottom up you have
case series case reports then you have
case control studies then you have
cohort studies then you have rcts and
then at the top you have systematic
reviews and meta-analyses so they
propose that for everything but
systematic reviews and meta-analyses
instead of just like straight lines
denoting differences between them it
should be kind of wavy lines to denote
that you know in general randomized
control trials are
higher quality evidence and more
valuable than cohort studies but a
really really good cohort study might be
more valuable than a somewhat poorly
done rct uh you know cohort studies
generally more valuable than case
control studies but a good enough case
control study might be more valuable
than a poorly done cohort study
etc so that that's kind of what they're
getting at with the wavy lines
and then they just lop off the top of
the pyramid uh so systematic reviews and
meta-analyses are no longer on the
pyramid itself it's kind of the the
handle of a magnifying glass that you
can peer through to look at the other
types of evidence which i think is a
nice way of looking at it because
ultimately they they are
aiming to give you uh perspective on the
original research that's been published
um but ultimately like original
investigations are are the foundation
like that that needs to get done if you
want to review it um and yeah it seems
like there's
more and more focus on pumping out
systematic reviews and meta-analyses
potentially to some extent at the
expense of original research yeah and to
be fair i know people are going to be
thinking you're very very dumb huge
blind spot there is some possibility
that
covid related lab closures are fueling
what we're seeing the last year or two
you know but
but like i said this divergent seems
like it was starting around like 2015 so
like we'll see if in the next few years
if it corrects and it was just a little
bit of a blip
but um i don't know time will tell we'll
see i do like their magnifying glass
approach i think that's better than my
electron cloud but uh
this is the
this is the second time that i've
regretted thinking independently uh
because it never gets me anywhere
because like every time i have something
that starts to approximate a decent
original idea i realized that somebody i
later find out that somebody already had
it
i told you the story about when i
invented a statistical technique as a
graduate student
and
then i found out it had been invented
about 50 years ago and then was replaced
about 30 years ago with something better
yeah uh never try to think on your own
it will get you nowhere in life that's
my conclusion i could not agree more so
i i have just like one little thing to
add to this this segment while we're
ah just just generally talking [ __ ]
about scientific publishing talking
talking shop not talking [ __ ] sure it's
it's all a matter of perspective um
but so i i came across uh something on
twitter the other day uh a new paper uh
from
uh
a journal of clinical epidemiology by
gabilica and colleagues title is mini
researchers
it's a perspective paper
many researchers were not compliant with
their published data sharing statement
colon mix method study so the the title
gives the findings away
but in in general there's kind of
at least like socially a push towards
open science
and part of open science is data sharing
and
data sharing is valuable for a couple of
reasons
one is
uh you know in terms of kind of like
an enforcement mechanism almost if
someone wanted to do something kind of
iffy with their data
let's say to put it nicely uh if you
know
that you will have to share data with
people who request it you might be less
likely to try to get away with some
shenanigans and if someone tries to get
away with some shenanigans it's uh it's
easier to catch that stuff if if data is
available
um
and then for kind of more positive
reasons uh i think we've talked about
this before so you know in discussing
systematic reviews and meta-analyses
they're very valuable uh but
if you can just do a meta on kind of
summary data in studies
that doesn't that doesn't let you answer
quite as many questions or estimate
things with quite as much precision
or probe quite as many sub-analyses as
you might be able to if
all of the data from the underlying
studies were available and then you
could do kind of a subject level
meta-analysis which is uh one step
better than just kind of like a normal
meta um so
that might sound like a small
distinction but it's pretty huge yeah in
terms of capability if you have the
individual level data from each of the
studies instead of just using the group
average
it's it's a tremendous step up yeah uh
and and you actually did one of one of
the first subject level metas uh that
i've seen in our field with the the p
ratio back and forth it doesn't count it
was in a blog it's not real science yeah
um
uh yeah so um yeah there are a lot of
reasons why
you might want open data or in data
sharing there's um you know there's bad
behaviors that it can cut off and then
there's positive outcomes that
are furthered by open data and data
sharing
and so most of the time when
when data is to be made available for a
study generally the data sheet isn't
just uploaded uh along with the article
uh there are pros and cons as to why
maybe you would want to just upload your
data sheet or why you might not want to
upload your data sheet that's a
conversation for another day but most of
the time when data is available
generally there is a data availability
statement that essentially says hey
we're not uploading our data sheet as an
attachment in a supplementary file but
the data is available upon reasonable
request
here's the corresponding author's email
address shoot them an email and
you know as long as your request is
reasonable we will share this data with
you so uh the the authors of this study
basically wanted to see how true is that
and i'm glad someone did this research
because in my experience uh data
availability statements are lies
there have been so many
they're aspirational yeah
again it depends how you frame it uh but
yeah there have been so many times where
i'm reading a study i'm like oh this is
interesting i i'd like to get into this
a little bit more uh you know the the
journal side it'll say like data is
available upon reasonable request and i
say cool i'm going to ask for the data
i'm a reasonable guy i'd like to request
it and so i have asked for for data and
i think my requests are reasonable i've
asked for data
probably 40 or 50 times and i've gotten
it like twice
so in my experience yeah there are
data availability statements are mostly
[ __ ] did you know those people the
the two that yeah one of the two yeah
so yeah in terms of just cold emails
we're about like one out of fifty so not
not great uh so
the the authors of this study um
essentially wanted to
study this phenomenon in a more
systematic way so they they pulled up
like 3 000 plus articles that had data
availability statements the most common
one was the the type that i just
mentioned where it says data is
available upon reasonable request and
they wanted to see
of those
if we make a reasonable request how many
data sets will we actually get uh and so
of
like close to 1800 uh requests
uh close to 1700 uh there were close to
1700 instances of the corresponding
authors either simply ignoring the email
like not responding which
could be an intentional choice could be
people changing institutions and the the
corresponding author email address no
longer works but uh so either getting no
response or getting a response and the
researchers saying no you can't have the
data uh
and then um
only a hundred there were only 122
instances out of close of eight close to
1800 where people did actually turn over
the requested data so that's that's a
success rate of 6.8 percent uh
and they also like they they emailed uh
authors who didn't have data
availability statements as well
basically wanting to see how many of
these people will turn over their data
compared to the people who say that
they're willing to turn over their data
and it was basically the same
so
basically those data availability
statements are just kind of placebos
like people kind of gesturing in the
direction of like yeah we believe in
open science we believe in open data but
uh
when the rubber meets the road 93 of the
time uh yeah those those data
availability statements are
i don't want to i don't want to impugn
any single person's honor but in terms
of like on a systematic level
on average those statements are lies
like yeah they say you can have the data
93 of the time you can't have the data
yeah and there's also just like it's
just structurally a bad way to do that
um
because you know a lot of times it's
like
you know either explicitly or implicitly
you feel like you're supposed to put
your institutional uh email address for
that as the corresponding author but
like
a lot of institutions won't even let you
keep access to your email after you
leave yeah and so there are some like
built-in mechanisms to make that
kind of the worst possible way to do
data gathering of just like yeah give me
put down your institutional email so it
looks like you're official uh and god
forbid you graduate or ever get a
different job then i'll have no way to
find you yeah which is not great but but
yeah i doubt that that explains 1700
instances yeah i mean if if you have a
yeah i i don't know i
i'm not going to uh
i'm not i'm not going to to take any
wild swings but i don't think that would
have moved the needle all that much yeah
uh yeah so that is our update on the
state of science uh things are looking
good
and moving on we've got some q and a's
i'm gonna like go rapid fire get a few
in to make sure that we have some good
uh practical takeaways from this episode
uh first of all i've got a question from
harry
uh harry has a question after listening
to the recent episode about calories
so methods like tdee calculators can
only go so far and you have to adjust
from there but what exactly does adjust
mean
is there more nuance than just
estimating a total daily energy
expenditure and then finding out weeks
or months later if it roughly worked um
so first there's just like this
straightforward uh
answer of you know this whole adjustment
process what are we really doing
uh and greg you've written two articles
that i think explain this really well
just talking about the
quantifiable mathematical link between
changes in body tissues in body mass
and
energy balance so i'm going to link both
of those
articles in the show notes
one is stronger by science dot com slash
energy balance calories the other
stronger by science.com
macro factor algorithms philosophy so
this uh general concept is core to the
way that macro factor generally works in
terms of algorithmic algorithmic
adjustments uh the idea here is that
you know if you can look at
the relative change in the total amount
of body tissues using body weight as a
proxy for that making some estimations
about how much of the tissue changes fat
mass versus lean mass you can actually
by tracking your nutrition intake and
tracking your body weight and body
composition changes
you can
quantify an estimate of your energy
balance and so for example
if you assume a particular caloric
intake should get you on track with your
intended rate of weight loss
but you're noticing that weight loss is
a little bit faster than than you
intended you're noticing that fat mass
is being lost at an accelerated rate you
can actually go in and quantify okay
how much larger is my energy deficit
than i actually intended and so then you
can make an adjustment uh either to your
extra your energy expenditure or most
likely your energy intake because it's a
little bit more easily modifiable
and you can do that adjustment process
so uh the good news you know the
question asked is this the type of thing
where you just have to you know take a
swing at it and then figure out three
months later oh i gained a bunch of fat
but i didn't want that to happen the
good news is it doesn't have to take
that long it doesn't have to be this
really extended timeline if you're able
to track
you know very precisely and really keep
an eye on things you can do this
adjustment process as you go
i will say that i think
a good software can be very helpful for
this it can be
exceedingly difficult to try to make
very small adjustments uh if you're just
kind of using the naked eye looking at a
spreadsheet and saying do i feel like
i'm on the right track here in terms of
my weight loss or weight gain trajectory
uh one of the the big value adds in my
opinion of a software like macro factor
is that and we're not the only one it's
not like a sales pitch here but one of
the things that i think macro factor
does really well
is it does really nice weight trending
features and helps you kind of quantify
what does my energy balance actually
look like here what kind of adjustments
need to be made now to get back on the
intended rate of weight change or just
get on on track with maintenance
so with a good weight trending feature
it can kind of sort through the
noisiness of day-to-day body weight
data and help you identify what kind of
adjustment has to be made before you
have to do something like
wait four months and see if you gain six
pounds you know it can facilitate making
those adjustments
in a much more uh
quicker time scale which you know can
can potentially potentially save you
from some uh some lost time if if you
were way off base with your estimate
you'd like to figure that out sooner
rather than later but like i said i'm
going to link those articles in the show
notes and they go into a little bit more
detail about exactly
what is the uh the theory underlying
that adjustment process and then how
something like our algorithm would go
about doing that
um
okay next question i'm going to do a
couple about creatine one's really quick
the other is a little bit more in depth
so brian asked are you able to
functionally use the extra water that
you store from creatine
would you be able to utilize that to you
know for example prevent dehydration
and the the short answer is yes so i'll
link in the show notes a really nice
review paper
uh that was actually written by a former
roommate of mine uh eric sobalewski uh
he was
and is was and is an excellent scientist
he gave me the gem one time we were in
the lab i was asking him a question
about study methods and he said if you
can't measure it in pounds it's not
worth measuring
uh i think in his world
every study would either measure
squatter bench press and that that'd be
the end of it um you also you teed
yourself up for a really good bill hicks
reference and then completely whiffed
so he used to be a good scientist still
is but he also used to be
yeah that's fine
um
so anyway sobalewski uh was the lead
author of this paper and in this paper
which i said you know like i mentioned
i'll link it in the show notes
um
uh a quote here a number of studies have
demonstrated that when recommended
amounts of creatine are consumed
creatine does not appear to increase the
risk of heat related problems during
exercise and may actually have a
positive influence on core temperature
and heart rate responses there's some
indirect evidence indicating that
someone who is taking creatine and is is
kind of you know their muscles are
saturated with it they're holding some
extra water weight theoretically uh it
does seem to have a neutral to slightly
positive effect on things that would be
indicative of uh dehydration related to
heat stress so uh
i wouldn't expect it to make a big
difference uh but but can you use that
water uh my answer would be yes uh in
terms of dehydration or preventing heat
related illness while exercising
very neutral to slightly positive effect
would be expected there uh
so sobalewski also taught me how to do
uh
evoked
muscle twitches uh he taught me the hard
way by just zapping the [ __ ] out of my
femoral nerve and god that is not it's
not like it's it's the worst kind of
thing because uh so he was doing uh
electrically stimulated um
contractions of my quads i think no i
think he might have been yeah he was
doing electrically uh i forget which
muscle we were targeting and which nerve
but he was zapping the hell out of my
nerve my muscle was contracting over and
over
and uh it's one of those it's in that
awful area where it doesn't
hurt enough and it's not uncomfortable
enough to actually complain about it
yeah but it's also not fun yeah i was
like i don't like this it's like uh
it's like the most
it's like somewhere between like a
really intense pins and needle sensation
and like slightly burny yeah and just
like a bit of a cramp yeah if you're
doing enough of them so yeah it's one of
those things where you're like i can't
really get too whiny about this because
i'd be a little embarrassed but i also
don't like this yeah that's that's how
you feel about toe injuries
yeah toe injuries suck they ruin your
day they do but in the grand scheme of
things you can't really complain about
them because we will be like it's your
toe come on just deal with it exactly
yeah so uh hopefully that's a a very on
topic answer for that question uh
another question that i think is really
fascinating uh it's by john and the
question is
basically what's the deal with research
looking at cognitive benefits of
creatine supplementation
john mentions he he saw some articles
years ago talking about how exciting and
promising this is but hasn't really hurt
a lot since
there's some interesting ins and outs of
the creatine literature when it comes to
cognitive stuff i think
i do think there's a little bit of bias
uh in the sport nutrition world where
like creatine does really well with
muscle stuff and i think people
there's just this kind of this glow
surrounding creatine where you're like
oh it's so great it's got to be
incredible for bone and it's got to be
incredible for the brain and it's got to
be incredible for every organ system and
every tissue and like you know you can
go through one by one and say okay
there's strong evidence here there's
decent evidence over here and all all
down the list so i don't want to sound
like i'm like a creatine skeptic or
anything creatine is excellent but when
it comes to the brain stuff uh there's a
little bit more nuance to it so like
for example when we uh you know
supplement with creatine do a creatine
loading phase or take uh you know a
maintenance dose for you know a month or
two we see pretty appreciable pretty
large increases in
uh muscle creatine saturation it's far
more uh
muted when it comes to brain creatine so
like if you look at the studies where
they give creatine supplements and they
try to increase brain levels uh
i'm going to link a review in the show
notes but at the time that this review
was written i think in 2021 there had
been 12 studies looking at human uh
brain creatine levels after
supplementation
generally speaking uh so so nine of the
12 showed a significant increase in
brain creatine
and we're talking about a magnitude of
like five to ten percent i i am
intensely curious about this how are
they measuring that uh i imagine they're
not taking brain biopsies no i i think
they do the uh the like uh
the
you know how they do like in the muscle
when when you can look for like
carnosine content like the the tnmr i
think or the mrs
tms
no no um
whatever we'll look into there's like
some acronyms it's related to mri yeah
but they can look at particular uh
compounds within different tissues okay
non-invasively so like um with with
creatine and even in the muscle they'll
sometimes use this method it's very
similar to mri i think it's
mrs or nmr i'll have to look it up all
right we're going to look like dumb
asses when the show goes out i mean it's
some some acronym we're not experts in
medical imaging no we're not i feel like
we threw out more potential acronyms
there than the average person could so i
i feel good about our performance yeah
exactly um
pick three letters go yeah um but anyway
there is a non-invasive way to quantify
this stuff
usually looks like it goes up maybe five
to ten percent and i'll also note it
looks like
there's some pretty decent evidence that
you need a higher dose if you're trying
to move the needle with brain creatine
and the reason i say that is like when
they look at a vegetarian versus an
omnivore when you look at muscle
creatine you can figure out pretty quick
like vegetarians generally have lower
saturation of muscle creatine because
they're getting less in the diet it's
very straightforward if you look at
brain content vegetarian versus omnivore
there is not a
noteworthy or detectable difference so
the amount coming in from like a normal
diet is not even really moving the
needle with brain creatine a lot of
that's just getting synthesized
endogenously
you know like i said there is some
evidence that you can move the needle
with supplementation with high doses but
like some of these studies are
suggesting that you might need to do
like
four weeks of a loading dose so you know
muscle loading is like five or seven
days at 20 grams a day some of these
studies are suggesting like 20 grams a
day for a month uh
and i don't even know what the
uh how long you would have to maintain
that 20 gram dose i'm not really certain
uh if you have to do it for four weeks
that sounds more like a maintenance dose
to me yeah but but i mean i'm not going
to speculate about
how quickly creatine reverts to baseline
in the brain because i have absolutely
never looked at that at that data
one thing i will note though uh
guanadino acetic acid is a creatine
precursor if you're really interested in
cognitive benefits of creatine might be
worth looking into that it is available
as a supplement and it might be better
for increasing uh brain saturation of
creatine so it's kind of like a
citrulline versus arginine type
yeah yeah
there is some reason to believe that
taking that precursor might be more
effective uh and there is some some
research to back that up um so anyway
creatine in the brain is it affected by
dietary creatine intake from food
it's not really a big enough fluctuation
to move the needle uh even omnivores
aren't getting that many grams of
creatine in their typical diet um can
you move the needle with supplementation
probably but it takes a pretty high dose
when does this actually matter uh the
most promising research
showing some kind of benefits related to
uh cognitive processing or just like
recovery from brain injury it's usually
when there's some pretty noteworthy
stressors that that are actually
challenging the brain uh so we're
talking about uh you know they're
they're there's looking at things like
sleep deprivation uh alzheimer's disease
uh various pathologies influencing the
brain uh of course traumatic
major or mild traumatic brain injury
usually it's in the case of stressors
another one is like sleep deprivation or
hypoxia combined with exercise which is
energetically i think pretty demanding
on the brain uh usually you're going to
see these types of things in stress or
stressful situations for the brain um
so like your average person who's just
taking like five grams a day or they
have like a pre-workout with like three
grams a day
and they're like oh this is doing
wonders for my cognition on like a
normal day-to-day basis i'm honest i
mean i'm open to it but i'm pretty
skeptical based on the vibes i get from
the literature it's not something that's
been explored a great deal but i i it's
it's going to be neutral to to slightly
positive so i'm not trying to like
uh you know rain on anybody's parade but
you know i think the biggest likelihood
of benefit comes from really high dose
supplementation in the context of actual
you know stressful situations to the
brain like i said uh clinical
pathologies uh brain injuries sleep
deprivation things like that
but while i'm on this topic
uh there's one thing that i kind of have
to to mention
there was a thing going around back in
the day where everybody said
oh if you're a vegetarian you have to
take creatine otherwise your brain
simply is not going to work uh and
as you can tell from the things i've
said already
that's a weird statement because like
vegetarian versus omnivore brain
creatine levels are very similar so you
might be wondering where that came from
as far as i can tell that was largely
driven by one paper
uh and it was uh a trial where kind of
like the creatine and like does creatine
make you bald
yeah yeah or does does caffeine make
creatine ineffective concerns yeah
although that one's getting up there
that's got like five papers yeah but i'm
saying like initially yeah just based on
one thing
it's weird like the the supplement with
maybe the most research on it seems like
the things people discuss the most are
maybe the least supported uh
aspects in that entire body of research
yeah yeah but anyway so like with the
vegetarian omnivore thing people are
like oh for the cognitive effects
vegetarians very much need it if you go
to the paper that everybody cites to say
that the
only defensible conclusion
is not that
creatine supplementation has a special
effect for cognition and vegetarians
it's that creatine makes omnivores way
dumber and vegetarians are simply immune
to that effect like that is the direct
interpretation of the data do i believe
that absolutely not i think it was a
false positive that caused just a fluky
poor performance in the omnivore group
on the cognitive i think it was like a
memory task or something like that but
yeah so like people said like okay uh
this
for some reason vegetarians who were on
creatine did not suffer this huge
drop-off in cognitive performance and
that just got kind of twisted around
into saying creatine has a way more
favorable cognitive effect in
vegetarians when that's just
not at all what the data actually showed
so it was kind of like a
misinterpretation that through a game of
telephone really picked up in the
research world and then got kind of
relayed outside of the research world
so
conclusions here
creatine is nice it's it's very very
good for
high intensity exercise performance
there's little glimpses that it does
nice stuff for other systems in the body
other tissues other organ systems there
there's you know i'm not trying to be
negative about creatine it's very very
nice the cognitive stuff isn't quite as
supported for like day-to-day use like i
said uh
you know traumatic brain injury various
pathologies impacting the brain maybe
sleep deprivation um you know there are
instances where creatine appears to be
somewhat helpful
but generally speaking it takes a pretty
high dose uh so yeah i i think that's uh
that's about all i have to say about uh
cognitive aspects of creatine might be
slightly helpful with a normal dose
that's kind of you know that the
standard five grams a day that you take
for exercise might be helpful in some
situations but i i wouldn't uh i
certainly like you know sometimes people
are like you know what i'm not noticing
anything in the gym but i'm afraid to go
off creatine because i don't want to get
dumber yeah i i don't think there's
any evidence to support that type of
approach
makes sense to me um all right i think i
yeah i think i've covered what i wanted
to cover here uh what do you have for
the q a yeah so i've got two uh
i think you focused on the facebook
thread so i went to reddit uh and so one
from rose curry
uh is there any detriment to mouth
breathing versus nose breathing either
chronically or during exercise
so i mean based on
uh
our comment section on instagram there
are plenty of mouth breathers who who
seem to be doing just fine um so that's
a snarky response uh but
i'm very interested in this because
anyone who's followed our podcast knows
that for the first two years of it i
couldn't breathe through my nose correct
yeah um yeah i know so i
i
looked into this before
and
um was it because you couldn't breathe
through your nose still can't
but no no it was because there was um
there was a thread in the stronger by
science facebook group maybe like three
years ago
uh i forget the name of it but there
there was a book about breathing and
this guy being like ah everyone breathes
wrong and that's what's causing all of
these uh health problems and so i
remember looking into into the research
then
and
it's
it's a
it's one of those areas of research
that's kind of a rorschach test i would
say because the thing about breathing
like uh habitually breathing through
your mouth versus your nose is
ultimately um so so you are probably
going to find some acute effects uh
largely because
um like like breathing um
like breathing is accomplished by by the
phrenic nerve like by and large that's
what controls the diaphragm
and the phrenic nerve is
an offshoot of the vagus nerve which
controls a lot of the parasympathetic
nervous system and so like you can you
can affect parasympathetic tone to some
extent
with like purposeful deep nasal
breathing and so like unsurprisingly if
if people breathe through their nose
versus their mouth acutely there are
some some small physiological
differences but i don't think that's all
that interesting because ultimately it's
a matter of of how are people breathing
most of the time day to day long term um
and when it comes to that that's not
really an area of research that's like
super amenable to rcts
because you know ultimately if we're
interested in like what are health
effects 20 years down the line like you
can't like breathing is a subconscious
process you don't you don't think about
it um
i mean unless you are thinking about it
because you're concerned about the way
you're breathing but most of the time
you're not thinking about it and so
however you breathe you're just gonna
kind of revert to it so it's not really
amenable to long-term interventions and
so for any of this stuff it's it's very
very difficult to establish causation
and so you can find some areas of
research
where there are some
[Music]
negative effects that are associated
with predominantly breathing through the
mouth versus the nose so poor sleep
quality um
there's some indication that it might uh
have an effect on on learning so people
who are like behind in school tend to
breathe through their mouth at a
slightly higher rate than than people
who aren't um
and but you know it's one of those
things where it's hard to say whether
the the breathing pattern itself is
causing those differences in outcomes
that you're seeing so if if you're
uh if you're on board with the idea that
breathing through your nose is good
breathing through your mouth is bad you
can look at that and be like oh boom
like this is evidence of of what i think
and what i believe
if you're more skeptical you could look
that and say ah it's it's mere
association and
i personally
think that it's
either
mere association or potentially even
reverse causation so another thing that
happens is
when you are
experiencing some amount of of stress
partic both physical stress and
psychogenic stress you become more
likely to breathe through your mouth uh
largely because like that's kind of part
of the fight-or-flight response like
your your breathing rate picks up uh so
you can like fuel your muscles
for exercise like do good oxidative
metabolism in case you either need to
fight something or run away and so you
know does breathing through your mouth
like cause an elevated stress response
or
are people who are just generally
experiencing more stress more likely to
breathe through their mouths you know
it's it's hard to say uh which which one
it is i think it's i think it's more
just that people who are experiencing
more stress are are breathing through
their mouths um
and you also don't know if there's some
sort of like
major uh confounding factor in play so
you know maybe people who
breathe through their mouth also
like maybe two people in this room do so
due to chronic sinus issues and maybe
there are deleterious effects of living
with chronic sinus issues and the
breathing through your mouth is simply a
symptom of
whatever is actually the root cause of
the problem the sinus issues themselves
or whatever is causing the chronic sinus
issues um so yeah
it is an area of research where if you
go into it looking for evidence that
breathing through your nose is good and
breathing through your mouth is bad
it is not hard to find that evidence if
you go into that area of research more
skeptical and you want to say like hey
i'm looking for really solid stuff that
actually
you know demonstrates causal evidence
for some of this stuff you're going to
have a really hard time finding that so
it's
it's not hard to get out of it what you
want to get out of it i personally am
skeptical that it matters all that much
um
i i think either reverse causation or
confounding effects are are far more
likely than just breathing through your
mouth itself per se being bad um but
yeah i
i will say that i don't think there's a
really really firm answer there yet
uh let's see the other one i wanted to
answer
was by what you expect double underscore
uh
who who says slash asks uh something
i've wondered for a while why do a lot
of people seem to somewhat assume that a
lot of nutrition principles for health
don't apply to them just because they
lift weights are active and or have
above average body comp examples include
thinking that high intakes of saturated
fat and sodium especially sodium are
permissive to health outcomes just
because of individual activity slash
body comp status which is of course not
true because they have linear
independent associations with high blood
pressure slash heart disease etc i've
heard so many versions of quote it
probably doesn't matter because you're
active slash aren't obese close quote
and i often think that advice isn't
always as accurate as some assume i
wonder where the sentiment comes from
slash if there are notable examples of
this you'd like to mention
so
uh yeah i i do think that that is a
is a good thought and something that may
be nice for a deep dive at some point
but i i do think that it's definitely
something that's kind of a case-by-case
basis and i think that there are several
um
several unstated assumptions that go
into
that type of conclusion that type of
analysis so so just kind of diving into
it
that sort of statement like hey if
you're active and have decent body comp
like this nutrition principle for health
doesn't really apply to you sometimes
that is true um so for example we've
talked about this on the podcast before
some people are concerned about high
sugar intake or high fructose intake in
particular
and i mean as far as that goes like to
simplify
a relatively large body of literature
there might be something to that like if
you're
relatively sedentary and consuming a lot
of sugar there might be some some
negative downstream effects of that but
if you are
quite active have relatively high sugar
intake especially if you're also in a
calorie deficit
it seems like it just doesn't matter so
there are there are such certain
situations where
a nutrition recommendation with with
health in mind does apply to one
population and doesn't apply to another
population
um
i also think
that one of the things motivating this
this type of fault
is sometimes just to kind of like get
oneself off the hook for a way that you
have to eat in pursuit of some other
goal so for example um
you know if someone is a crossfit
athlete or an endurance athlete or even
just like a super heavyweight
powerlifter or strongman and in order to
fuel your performance and and just
maintain weight um if you're trying to
get down five six thousand calories per
day
that's going to be pretty hard to do if
you're trying to eat like quote unquote
clean
and so
imagine trying to do that on a low sugar
low sodium diet insane yeah i ca i can't
even conceive of that um
and i don't think most people can
conceive of that and so you know i think
that uh people who primarily have
performance goals might want to tell
themselves like look
i got to do what i got to do to get down
this many calories uh performance is
very important to me this is how i have
to eat to fuel my performance
uh and so
i'm just going to assume that this is
all fine uh like i i think that there i
think that there's some amount of that
uh in play
um
i also think it is true to some extent
that
some of the specific benefits that one
might get from eating
like quote unquote healthy foods
are also benefits that one would get
from exercise so for example
there are plenty of benefits from eating
antioxidant rich fruits
and and we kind of joked about uh
paul saladino being afraid of vegetables
and and defense chemicals and vegetables
uh last episode so like it is true that
there are chemicals and vegetables that
are like trying to kill things that are
eating them we are big enough that those
chemicals don't kill us but they do
cause some amount of oxidative stress
and one of the reasons vegetables are
good for you is that your body responds
to that stressor of the vegetable by
increasing endogenous antioxidant levels
endogenous antioxidant activity so that
that that's one of the i think that's a
very cool thing about vegetables that's
one of the reasons they're good for you
in addition to like fiber intake and
phytonutrients and other stuff um but
yeah so
you know those are those are discrete
benefits of two categories of food that
are typically thought to be very good
for you those are also benefits you get
from exercise so when you exercise that
causes oxidative stress and as a result
your body's endogenous antioxidant
system produces more antioxidants the
activity of those antioxidants increases
so
there there's
you know i i do think that it's still
probably an additive benefit like
exercising and eating vegetables
probably better than exercising and not
eating vegetables but
if you exercise and eat vegetables there
there are a lot of similar things going
on on a cellular level that you would
see in someone who doesn't exercise and
does eat vegetables like it you're
causing similar physiological effects
maybe making vegetable intake slightly
less important still important still
good for you but you you are already
getting some of those same adaptations
just from doing exercise so i think
that's a dynamic
as well
and there's also
kind of a
similar situation where sometimes
exercise
is directly attenuating some of the
potentially deleterious impacts of a
food so also true yeah one of the things
that came up was like sodium and and i
think about like
an endurance runner who is
running like crazy uh which you know
being having high cardio respiratory
fitness generally tends to drive blood
pressure downward and they're just
sweating out a ton of sodium during
their you know runs in the summer and
things like that so
you can see where for that individual
there are directly protective mechanisms
in place that counteract the the kind of
primary thing you'd be concerned about
which would be the sodium in increasing
blood pressure yeah yeah so there there
is
to to some extent the the things that
people are the the the
sorts of statements that this uh uh
question comment was responding to
sometimes it's just true so in the case
of sugar intake sometimes uh you know it
would still be good to eat healthy
things but
you you get yourself off the hook a
little bit because you're you are
causing similar physiological
adaptations from doing exercise uh
however there is a very large kernel of
truth to what what you expect was asking
here on reddit um and i think that a lot
of times
when people either say
you know hey you don't have to worry
about this nutrition advice for health
because you're exercising or they tell
themselves that like yeah you know what
i'm i'm healthy i'm exercising i don't
need to worry about this stuff all that
much
i think that i think that implicitly
what people are often doing
is comparing risk levels between
populations and they kind of have
implicitly a population in mind where
they say okay this population is at an
elevated risk and i consider this level
of elevated risk to be too much
so as long as what i'm doing keeps me
below that level of risk i am therefore
good so for example
uh the comment mentioned saturated fat
intake and so you know if you're pretty
active and you consume a decent amount
of saturated fat your risk of
cardiovascular disease
is probably lower than someone who is
sedentary and consumes the same amount
of saturated fat and it may be
comparable to someone who's sedentary
and consumes very little saturated fat
and so you look at that and you say well
okay i'm comfortable with the level of
risk of being sedentary and consuming
low saturated fat i am active therefore
i can consume a fair bit of saturated
fat and not be at
elevated risk relative to the level of
risk i am comfortable with so you might
be able to lower your risk even more if
you're quite active and consumed very
low saturated fat but just kind of what
what you're implicitly pegging your
brain to
uh in terms of what you perceive to be
risk you're comfortable with versus
uncomfortable with you know the the way
you're eating given your activity levels
still keeps you below that level of risk
that you're comfortable with even though
you could probably reduce your risk
further uh if you wanted to
and
so i think that's largely what's going
on like i think people just kind of look
at it and they're like okay what is
the general health risks for people who
are sedentary
and engage in all of the most healthy
dietary behaviors
so you kind of look at that and you're
like okay
if i am
active and exercising and have good body
composition what can i get away with
for my level of risk to still be the
same as those people like i think that's
kind of
the mental math people are doing and i
also think that that comports pretty
well with some people's stated reason
for exercising like it's it's not
uncommon uh to hear people say you know
hey hey i exercise so i can eat what i
want without gaining weight i i think
that there's to some extent and very
understandably so
a lot of people who don't
want to change their dietary choices and
don't want to change their dietary
behaviors and so it's it's just a
question of
given the fact that you've predetermined
you're not going to make those dietary
changes how can you still
get your risk of chronic health problems
down to a level that you're comfortable
with and and so i think that's
ultimately what people are doing
and then what they'll tell you is hey
actually it's fine to do this because
i'm exercising and that doesn't
necessarily mean that doing those good
things wouldn't further reduce their
risk ultimately what it means is their
their risk level is at a level they're
comfortable with given the fact that
they're exercising and and like i said i
think that's a very understandable thing
um
i think that
there is maybe too much of an
inclination among particularly like
science people to
say very confidently like oh food is
fuel that's all it is like you're you're
putting fuel in the gas tank to fuel
performance whatever body comp outcomes
you're interested in when like food and
eating behavior is a lot more complex
than that like there's uh you know there
you there's an emotional response that
you get from eating like you might have
certain memories and feelings around
particular meals there's a social aspect
to it um there's certainly a cultural
aspect to it as well uh and so you know
i completely
understand uh people who
largely don't want to make dietary
changes and their brain kind of goes to
okay given that i'm not going to do this
[ __ ]
what can i do to still get my chronic
disease risk to a level i'm comfortable
with
but then i think those statements of hey
i am exercising so none of this stuff
affects me i i do think that that's
at least to some extent oftentimes
mental gymnastics that people are doing
to justify decisions that they had
already made
yeah i'm glad you mentioned the cultural
component because one of my favorite
things to do when i'm traveling is to
sample the local fuels
and see
how differently my body performs that's
kind of the main reason i do it yeah i
mean
yeah like you know 93 octane is the same
everywhere but uh
you know you're probably going to get a
lot better empanadas in mexico than you
will in pennsylvania right all right uh
i do have one more question i wanted to
get to uh patrick umphrey
goddamn asked me uh do i do anything
specific for back pain oh wait no yeah
yeah specifically the back pain i get
from carrying greg on every show
not necessarily every show
for the time being yes because he is
currently a permanent guest co-host but
anyway patrick i
appreciate your question i definitely
understand for sure where it's coming
from
uh but paradoxically it's kind of nice
because sometimes
greg's uh mistakes and oversights give
me
ideas for future segments it kind of
inspires me to pick up the slack and
that's what's going to play us out today
i need to do some cleanup and correct uh
fake news greg over here no i'm going to
jump in real quick here's a here's a
history lesson patrick
the whole point of this podcast
initially was because we were bringing
eric into the business and people knew
who i was they didn't know who he was
and so i was like okay what what is a
venue where we can introduce eric to the
audience and they can feel like they
they can get to know him and that he's
not just like the weird other dude who
is now along for the ride in this
business that greg built and so
magnanimously we said
eric podcast and you'll be the main guy
and this is how
we can endear you to the audience and
now you turn around and you take
patrick's question
as
uh a foot in the door for you to talk
[ __ ] when it was pre-deter the podcast
is this way
out of the goodness of my heart
and uh i am
i am just furious that you would uh you
would stoop to this level
yeah that's not how i remember it uh but
that's okay well that's that's exactly
what happened uh okay so no this is uh
actually really cool so we had talked a
little bit about the origins of exercise
science as a field
and
my understanding much like yours like
the the kind of short cliff notes
version is like oh man harvard fatigue
lab it was really sick that's where it
all started but i was kind of curious
about digging in before that and kind of
what was around before
harvard fatigue lab really hit its
stride and of course i'm i'm joking
about corrections here because with the
field like exercise science or exercise
physiology you're never going to be able
to pinpoint an exact start date because
it's many different fields combining
into an applied focus right so
like i remember back in the day rippetoe
wrote an article and he was like
exercise science is so dumb what you
should be doing is studying
physics and chemistry and biology and i
was like did you google one curriculum
for exercise science
also well no i mean his his his point
was a
hilariously self-serving point because
he he said like just just get a degree
in a hard science so you can learn like
what science is and how to do it and
then yeah like the exercise science is
kind of a kiddie pool of science and so
if you if you get to know a real science
you'll be able to apply that knowledge
and those skills to
to the exercise thing
and
to some extent i kind of agree with that
uh but also
his background is in geology yeah and of
the hard sciences that one might be able
to apply to uh to exercise science i i
would definitely put like biology and
chemistry uh
a little bit ahead of geology personally
well but geology is the hardest hard
science because it's literally rocks
that is true that is true so that's my
response i i stand corrected yeah uh but
but you know uh
that that's kind of to me the beauty of
an exercise science degree is they're
like hey before you even think about
doing exercise science you have to go
through chemistry biology physics etc
but anyway that's beside the point
talking about the origins of exercise
science as a field a little timeline of
important stuff i i was looking through
a textbook by catch catch and mcardle
this one was actually mcardle catch and
catch i think they alternate the order
with each edition i was looking at the
seventh edition and it actually gives a
really nice history of the field and
they go all the way back i mean they're
talking about stuff like
several hundred years ago like way
before the 1700s because anything to do
with chemistry and physics you could say
oh yeah we use some of that but uh i
kind of jumped to the part here uh
some of the the applied anatomy stuff
was really picking up in the 1700s and
two things that i thought were just
interesting
uh
there were two professors at the
university of bologna in italy
first university yeah so they were there
in the 1700s one was laura bassey
and she was actually
as i understand it the first woman to
earn a phd
uh and she actually had to conduct her
experiments at home because they're like
a woman phd we don't know how to deal
with this like we are we don't know how
to manage this
we never expected it kind of
uh which is obviously not good but it's
kind of an interesting look at like
what the the first woman with a phd like
what that looked like as a working
environment was like doing your
experiments at home and trying to keep
up with the other professional aspects
of working at this university uh
alongside her uh also working in anatomy
at the same university was anna marandi
manzolini
and she was an expert at creating wax
models and also wood models of different
organ systems even things like the inner
ear and they still used her models in
the medical school for hundreds of years
like they were so good
so anyway jump forward let's talk
1860s at amherst college uh edward
hitchcock jr was a physician he was
hired as a professor of hygiene and
physical education in the department of
physical culture he was appointed in
1861
and you could claim that he is the first
exercise physiology professor just based
on the the tasks that he handled his
interest areas he was largely influenced
by the writings of austin flint jr who
was a physician who wrote extensively
about exercise
and like i said he was appointed in 1861
and was involved with some very
exercise physiology type research that
involved civil war
soldiers back in the 1860s
jumping to harvard in 1891 they
established their first formal exercise
physiology lab so harvard actually had
an ex-fizz lab before the harvard
fatigue lab i didn't know that prior to
this
so they also established the first
degree program around that time in this
field
now the big ten
they also were pretty active they had a
number of departments that were
considered
physical culture slash kinesiology
michigan state for example
they what they currently have is a
kinesiology department they say it began
in 1899 uh and
the team up north had a program in 1894.
illinois had a program 1895. but here's
a fun fact for you michigan state
this like physical culture kinesiology
program
from 1899
through 1971
so only like 50 years ago
that the head of that department at some
point in their time at the college also
served as the head coach of the football
team that's pretty cool which is wild
because like
dude the divergence that college
football has had since then like that
university michigan state pays their
head football coach 9.5 million dollars
a year
if you could still get that gig if you
were like the chair of an exercise
science department i would not be an
assistant blogger if they were
if there were 10 million dollar
contracts to be had it'd be like hey
you're the chair of the department you
want to coach the buckeyes i'd be like
yeah that would be great um yeah so uh
in 18 1889 i think the there were three
articles about physical activity in the
american journal of physiology uh there
is a lab at carnegie institute looking
at energy metabolism in 1904 in the
1920s a series of other labs popped up
uh george williams college
uh university of illinois springfield
college in the 1920s and then the
harvard fatigue lab comes along in 1927
and of course made huge strides really
accelerated the field and
is largely viewed as kind of the
inflection point where the field really
started to take off uh now of course the
summary i just gave like i said it's
from mcardle catch and catch seventh
edition i mostly covered the american
stuff here i was just kind of following
the text it's very important to
recognize there are things happening all
over the world uh major breakthroughs in
denmark sweden norway and finland
specifically around this time also some
stuff going on in france i believe uh
but yeah i was it was happening all in
this time frame kind of popping up all
over the world and people said listen we
need to get as swole as we possibly can
and by the 1890s it was pretty clear
that we all needed to get uh very very
fit and study how to do that so
yeah it's it's a really interesting uh
history of how this field came together
and
a lot of the earlier uh justifications
for establishing these departments and
labs
unsurprisingly it was focused on
military yeah creating the human war
machine uh and figuring out why
humans fatigue and how to make them more
physically robust and resilient um but
yeah it took off from there
well good deal man all right uh so i
think that does it for this episode of
the stronger by science podcast we had a
little bit of everything some meta
science
some on topic stuff and a little history
lesson uh so as always thank you for
joining us and we will see you next week
with another episode
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you